I think we're good to start well welcome
this is the tutorial about visualizing
the 2019 measles outbreak here in New
York City using Python and so I already
mentioned the repository but I'm gonna
try to make this more interactive here
in the life tutorial first I'd like to
thank everyone involved in organizing
these events and also thank you for
selecting my proposal for this tutorial
secondly I'd like to thank the New York
City Health Department for making the
measles data available it's actually
from all the areas that had measles this
year from what I could find was the the
jurisdiction that provided the best data
even though it was just raw tables in a
webpage it was still very good and so a
couple of disclaimers this is a personal
project is not associated with any
company or an employee I'm not
affiliated with NYC health so I believe
I capture the data correctly and I'm
represent and visualizing it correctly
here but it's possible I did some
mistakes if that's the case it's my
fault it's nothing to do with when NYC
health and of course this is not for
medical advice and so these do not this
tutorial notebook is verbose and that's
intentional for someone who may be
following it outside of the conference
and here I'm gonna try to make it more
more of a discussion more interactive
and feel or feel free to ask questions
any time you don't understand something
or just have questions about what's
going on all right
my name is Carlos and I'll give a little
introduction about myself but first a
summary about what we're gonna do here
first the context as a as a general goal
this is kind of a good example of a
small project a small data project that
can help the community where you live in
understand an important an important
issue which is the case of the measles
outbreak which is important locally here
it was actually important national
national level because many other places
at the outbreaks so this year the u.s.
is amid the largest misses lot break
since 1992 and it would the measles that
I actually been declared eradicated in
2000 so you can see how bad it is it
goes back to before the disease was
eradicated in 2000 at the moment there
are there have been reported 1250 cases
as of October 13 not in the whole of the
US and most of those cases actually
about half of those cases were here in
New York City and fortunately the the
outbreak was declared over on September
3rd meaning there's no ongoing community
propagation since well once the
temperature they declared at the end of
the community propagation so there's the
there's been no more cases so far so the
the goals of this talk
the general goal is to discuss and show
how to create visualizations that help
understand the outbreak some very simple
visualizations like bar charts and some
more advanced I would say like the
bubble charts on the map of New York
City and those are the technical the
specific goal is to create that those
bubble that bubble map and those bar
charts that using to to the specific to
Python libraries Bakke in matplotlib and
will follow principles of I called here
clarity and context to make it is as
easy as possible to understand and as
clear as possible to understand what
what's going on okay and so these these
are these are our final products so it's
going to be creating this bar chart
about the New York City measles cases by
months which shows the progress over
time and this map of the new of New York
City showing the older neighborhoods
that add cases and the number of cases
in each neighborhood and also the names
of those neighborhoods and I'll explain
why I took the scene of showing that the
labels even though it may make the
visualization a little cluttered
basically it's me
because well I'm fairly new to New York
City and when I first learned about this
I'm actually I'm from Williamsburg where
most of the cases are I live in Williams
Worth and when I first looked at this
and I looked at the list of the
neighborhoods I didn't know where they
were so I'm I imagine four people are
new to New York City it's difficult for
them to know and I imagine my views for
some someone who lived here for a long
time may be difficult to know where some
of those neighborhoods are would you
know where those neighborhoods are if
you didn't see it in map so that was
kind of my trigger my trigger my initial
motivation and we also be creating these
these bar charts it's a horizontal bar
charts so these are or final goals that
that's what we are working towards here
okay so a more proper introduction so my
name is Karl the phones original from
Portugal
that's my the reason for my name in my
accent I'm passionate about using data
science to solve important problems I
have a diverse industry experience and
the background in in stem as I said
emerges from Portugal I first studied
physics I did a master's in physics
engineering there I ended up going to
Oxford doing research source a PhD which
I ended up not finishing because I moved
from academia to industry before before
that and in the last four years I've
been doing corporate consulting solving
data science problems for a variety of
clients and companies and and different
in different industries so more recently
I created these these missiles project
and I'll be happy to connect with you
guys on on LinkedIn okay so let's go
back to the what what motivated me to do
this this project and what may be your
motivations to look at this project and
what you can take from it so as I said
mine is motivation was that I live in
Williamsburg where most of the cases
were happening so I got and I have a
background in biomedical engineering so
I was curious about it and I started
doing research and I noticed that the
New York City Health Department provided
the date on their website
but the date is just some raw tables
I'll show you in a moment and as I said
the neighborhood situation I looked at
the list of neighborhoods and I didn't
know where they were now that I show you
this for example these these four
neighborhoods without showing them up do
you guys know where those are yeah so
the technical and practical motivation
is that this is was I think a nice
opportunity to learn practice and
actually showcase data skills
fundamental and advance the data skills
and in particular visualization projects
are very good to showcase your skills
like to to other people to recruiters
and so on so it that that's a practical
motivation for this project too and as I
said the on the background the general
motivation is that this is a good
example of all you can even a small data
project can help your community
understand an important subject and even
at this case was a national national
wide subject so still on part on the
introduction as related any data science
project it's important to understand the
background so you can better understand
what what you are doing and why you are
doing it and it's going to be important
to understand what Meisel is so to know
what what with auditions to create and
how to represent them and what
information to provide in those
visualizations so measles is a very
contagious disease that it's caused by
virus and it's transmitted by infected
people and they cough or sneeze in the
air
fortunately measles can be prevented
with with with vaccine called the MMR
vaccine which stands for measles mumps
and rubella which protects for those
three diseases and the Center for
Disease Control recommends that children
get two doses of the vaccine but you'll
you notice that the first dose is
between 12 and 15 months of age so the
first point is that newborns cannot have
the vaccine yet you have to wait until
until they are one year old to give them
that the vaccine that means that they
are going to be very vulnerable in their
first year or wife and that that's
that's an issue when there's an outbreak
going on so you imagine yourself with a
newborn living in a place we don't going
out measles outbreak and you'd be
concerned every
so and then the second does can also can
only be taken between four and six years
so even after you take the first does
the baby to get the first those yes to
wait until four years old until Cal get
the second and and get the most
protection possible indeed the one dose
is 93% effective and two doses increase
if the effectiveness up to 97% so and
just to wrap up the the context about
measles so a brief history of measles in
the u.s. the vaccine was introduct
introduct introduced in 1963 and before
that there were lots of cases and lots
lots of problems with measles so it's
estimated there were about three to four
million cases of those only about half a
million would be reported to to the
Center for Disease Control and from
those that were reported for 400 to 500
died so this is like 50 60 years ago and
people were a lot of people are dying
because of measles in addition to that
there were like 50,000 little eyes and
1,000 develop brain swelling firstly
since then the vaccine has been a great
success reduced immensely the number of
cases that by more than 99% and as I
said before in 2000 the measles was
declared eradicated in in the u.s.
however there's two measles in other
countries so when people can travel to
the u.s. that who may have measles or
people from the u.s. travel to those
countries and they are not vaccinated
may acquire measles and then come back
and transmit to other people are not
vaccinated so that's actually the the
most common case of how the outbreaks
have still happen in the US and close
the case in this year as well so as I
said this year is the largest outbreak
since 1993 and with 1,250 cases and how
about off of those guys were in New York
City that's why we're focused in New
York City and also because that's we are
living at the moment and also because
New York City is actually one that
provides the best data at the time I
looked at all the areas that they were
having the the measles outbreaks and
they have legal or no data and I'm going
to show you the the great data that's
available
from from the New York City Health
Department so go to the measles webpage
they have lots of information and then
they have this part where they have the
data tables and they show the cases by
neighborhood the cases by age and
vaccination status is this is a matter
there's a kind of matrix information
here I I used only the totals but
there's potential to do more
visualizations by doing a visualization
of this as a matrix plot for example but
that's a secondary it I focused on on
them on the main factors at the moment
and the cases by date so this is really
great that the New York City Health
Department provides this information no
other area that I could find provides
such good data so it's really good okay
so these were just screenshots in case I
couldn't load the website because the
date you saw is very small basically I
just collected it manually so I just
went to the page and typed it in excel
file in service in CSV files there was a
stage in the middle of the outbreak
where the date would be updated about
once a week so I was saving different
versions of the data so that they could
see the progress and so on but that's
the I'm not going to be talking about
that stage because we are now at the the
outbreak was declared over so we kind of
have a final version of the data given
that there are no more cases and they
don't reopen and start increasing the
counts so the final version of the data
is more clean there's only a version but
the the github repository as other
notebooks that deal with the fact that
the data was changing every week and I
created I was collecting the data
manuals as well and keeping all those
were those different versions and
something interesting I found is that if
you miss an update you can try to find
it on the web archive they take
screenshots of many websites and I could
find several versions of past versions
of the data by going to the web archive
so this was useful for this case and it
can be useful for other projects to me
working on where you find the webpage
with data and
the data is updated every once in a
while but you weren't there in the past
you can go to EV archive and try to see
if they have screenshots of that website
for from the past that you can use to
collect more data all right
and so we are in any help I can help you
to that's what we are here for all right
so I collected this data and I said in
CSV files but I just want to show you
here all the data looks like and it's
very simple so just gonna use pandas
table to open the data that already
stored and here you can see this is the
data by by age and you have the data for
the age group for kids under one year
old the age group of kids between one
and four year olds and five to 17 and 16
and over I also captured the the
reported total and the start and end
date so I always kept the dates to to
have that context information so when
you see a visualization it it tells you
what when does that data was collected
from so and the same for all the other
data tables they are you can all you can
load them all as pandas dataframes
and work with them so and I'm gonna be
showing each of them in more detail as
we create each of the visualizations
okay so now it's when I'm gonna start
running some some more code and any
questions so far here okay so the first
visualization is going to be the the
number of missile k's new missile cages
by months which gives you the idea of
the progression of the disease over time
and technically this is an example of
the simple vertical bar chart but on I
did several changes to the default so
I'm already showing here the the
the final outcome of this so if you if
you just do a bar chart on matplotlib
you you get to the fault which is this
one with the blue bars and I did several
modifications to try to make it more
clear and provide more information so
can can you guys tell me what what what
I removed or added what are the
differences let's what the differences
what the color okay does anyone know why
why I change the color yeah and if you
have any idea why I changed from blue to
reddish because it's bad actually so
with measles you get a reddish colored
rice on your skin so to give an
impression of the problem at hand and of
course in red is also indication of bad
yeah
so the color and you other differences
yeah other than the number of cases on
top of each bar to make it clear what
were to numb the exact numbers yeah
doors on two axes preacher and hopefully
easier to read and to understand yeah I
removed the frame and and the left axis
yes yeah let me try to twist too much
magnification maybe yeah now you can see
it oh yes and I added some lines what's
that for
yeah and to provide additional
information context so I'm telling that
you there what's the total number of
cases what's the time frame in which the
date words acquired which in this case
is implicit in the graph but the other
is not necessarily there's an important
line they're saying in April 2000
nineteen New York City increased its
vaccination efforts and when you look at
the map you could write to at the plot
you could do what what you see happening
in terms of dilution of the disease how
would you describe what happened in
terms of number of cases or
time yeah and when when did this change
happened the in this case the vaccine
was always here in New York City yeah
yeah so they in April they took strong
measures actually you may have seen in
the news they people could get fine by
not getting disease so did they change
they implemented the rule where you you
really do really pushing forward for
people to get vaccines was a little
polemic at the time because they were
threatening people with fines but if
this is not a causal confirmation of
what that they did caused the outbreak
to end but it's a good indication that
the actions they took in April helped
end the outbreak because after April the
number of cases decreased drastically
and progressively until August there
were no more no more cases and then
after that period without cases in
September third they declared the end of
the trend the transmission so again if I
didn't tell you that in April there
there was that action by the New York
City Health Department well I'll be you
you'd be missing an important point of
information which indicates u8y in April
things changed again it's not a causal
explanation this that is not enough to
tell that was their actions that led to
the end of the outbreak but it indicates
that their actions helped contribute to
the end of the outbreak all right any
more differences you can see there
yeah yes
so I increased the font all over so
everyone so it's easier for everyone to
see so I when I created these these
visualizations I I tried to make them so
that they would look nice on the laptop
but also on the phone because nowadays a
lot of people just look at stuff on
their phones so I that's why I make the
font big okay so let's look now at how
that actually you you actually you guys
went through of all over the notes that
all over the notes that I add here and
now I can run I can show you the exact
code and run these so let's see if I can
increase magnification and feel free to
ask questions if you have any questions
about the code so my approach was I
created individual super notebook for
each of the visualizations that I
created there was a lot of duplication I
could have tried to do all the
visualizations in one notebook but as
the outbreak was going on I was trying
different things so it was easier to
keep things modular and separated
so for each visualization I created I
would have a different notebook and this
is the notebook for the number of new
missile cases by month which is that
plot I showed you over there so let's
let's run this just to make sure let's
start a new kernel so the libraries you
can see the most important level here is
going to be matplotlib to do the
visualizations we load the libraries as
I said the data was collected from the
New York City Health missiles web page I
collected it manually saving a CSV file
and now I can load it so in this these
paths are all relative paths so it's
designed to work when you when you guys
also download the materials in your
computers it should work without having
to do any change so we're gonna read the
data and so here we have the data we
have information about the start and end
date of when the data collection happens
and we have the first months of
September 2018 goes until the end of
last month August 2019 and we have a
reported total number of cases so to
create those visualizations I showed you
we want to provide more context
contextual in context information and
here we're gonna extract the the start
date and end date initially I was
reporting the start date and end date
with the precision of the day but
because some of these visualizations
only show the months and I'm now showing
just the beginning of the start month in
the end months and that's what's
happening here I'm getting the start
months in ten months from the start date
and end date so this lambda function
what is doing is that it's looking
operating on this on these dates it's
reading this format first the year month
day and then transforming it to month
space year as a string which is going to
be the string that I'll be using to
provide those additional notes on the
plot if we wanted to provide the exact
day we could also provide the exact date
but it's not it's too much too detailed
it's not necessary in this case so we
also had the number of total cases to be
displayed as information in the in do
plot we had we have the total cases here
at in the final column and that's that's
how we are collecting the total cases
and actually unchecking that the total
cases match the sum of the individual
months so I always check the data that I
was collecting from them and during the
while the outbreak was going on I I came
across a few mistakes like the the the
number of cases would not add up to the
reported total and actually I told him I
send them an email and they were kind
enough to reply and they change they and
then the corrected on the website so
it's always good to check that the date
is correct and in this case the simple
simple check if they report the total
and the report individual parts just do
the Sam to make sure that
what they're reporting adds up and these
decays it does if it didn't it would
give me that warning message and because
it does it just doesn't give me anything
so and I'm selecting the exact data to
plot from from the data frame which is
just the data we actually be plotting on
the bar chart is the demands and the
cases from the September months to the
August 2009 teen so that's that's what
I'm extracting here now again I'm using
index references to the pandas dataframe
if you guys have any questions about
that or any other questions feel free to
interrupt in ask questions so again this
is the date the data that's actually
gonna be plotted and those nice labels
you saw there this is how they act they
are being created so I first I get all
the the month's labels from the column
names so I get all these all these all
these strings first and then what I do
is that to not repeat the year because
that that will become very repetitive
I only provide year in the first month
and the last month and actually if
there's a transitional from the one year
to the other I also provide it in
January so that that's what this code is
doing here and I I do new lines so that
you you give the months and then if you
want to display the year the year comes
out below two months so it's easier to
read and you can do a vertical bar chart
with labels that are thin enough to to
display and that spacing and be easy to
read so these are the demands levels you
get is September with a line-break 2018
then January is a New Year line-break
2019 and the last months is August the
line breaks as 19 and the rest are just
the months and so for contrast I created
here what was the default bar chart from
MATLAB without doing any modifications
so that's what I showed you initially so
this and again there you spotted several
of the issues like in particular the X
access labels that are difficult to to
read so I saved these to all these plots
as images so I could present them in
here in the tutorial and also in the
project webpage so at the end I'll be
showing you how I present all these
visualizations in a github page so it's
a live there everyone can see it and
read it so and to save the the images I
saved them both as PNG s and s VG's
ideally it's better to use SVG is
because it's a scalable format does not
lose an information but sometimes in
some places is difficult to use SVG so
that's why I also saved PNG versions and
here's where I'm creating the the
improved bar chart with all and
explaining all the the reason all the
the changes I'm doing to the default to
make it look better which were all the
changes that you already spotted so you
I think we can skip these information
forward so I actually I also changed the
font type because Arial is easier to
read than the default one so I'm quickly
I have I establish a base font size
which I'll be increasing or decreasing
as needed so in the title for example I
use the font size that's for four points
higher than the base so that I'm adding
the title there did this is the this is
just the line to create the bar chart
every all the other code is to improve
it so i-i've as someone as someone
spotted I removed the y-axis I removed
also the x-axis sticks only there was
like some little lines there that didn't
provide any help
so here's how I set the my defined
labels and this code is what what sets
the the number of cases on top of the
bars if you guys have any questions
about any particular code let me know so
this removes the frame around the around
around the the the bar chart and these
ads all the textual information by using
the information that was provoked that I
collected before the total number of
cases the start months the end months
this line is kind of hard hard coded and
this line as well because these this
information that does not really change
at least we've been the current final
version and information about the
sources the data comes from the NYC ELLs
and this image is always available at
the project on page in case people want
to go there and I use the different font
here with the monospaced font for the
information about the sources okay and
that that's how you get this
visualization the end so there are a lot
of changes there and if on when you do
your visualizations you may want to use
some of them others don't don't but I
hope this can be helpful when you do
your visualizations you can just take
some some parts of the of that of of the
code too
depending on whatever you need again we
say we save the this visualization as
PNG and SVG and for all the notebooks I
I like to save them as HTML for example
when when you are on github trying to
load a Jupiter notebook sometimes takes
a long time or doesn't load it so if you
have an HTML version you can just also
provide people the link to the HTML
version and it opens much quicker much
more quickly more quicker and if you
don't have internet and I'm doing this
presentation dot internet I'll at least
still and I having problems with Jupiter
I could still do this presentation we're
just showing the HTML versions which is
basically a printout of all of these
with all the images so I see I always
find it useful when working with
notebooks to print an HTML version of it
okay yeah and this is this is the simple
line you can use to do it okay so that
was the this example of a vertical bar
chart that in this case showed us the
progression of the disease over time and
highlights the fact that in April there
was this push from the New York City
Health Department to increase the
vaccination efforts and then the months
after that the the number of new cases
decreased and they didn't in August so
now I have three three more
visualizations for you guys for to show
you which is these horizontal bar charts
and the final one is the map so I just
want to check on time how much time I
have left okay do you do you have any
any questions so far
yeah when I was doing this I was
creating them and then looking at them
on on my laptop and on my phone I have
an Android and none of my wife's wonhui
has a an apple an iPhone so I tried
different things and I and I stopped
when I when I found something that
looked nice everywhere so that's why I
also changed the the font type Arial
seemed to be a good font to display on
your screens and when you look at the
phone it's really difficult to provide
so much information and then and be able
to read it easily on your phone so
that's why I increase the font and
change the font type and I try to make
the visualizations kind of taller than
wider because the phone screen is tall
it's not wide that that's that's a
challenge with the with the map of the
New York City because the area where the
measles happened kind of comes out as a
square there's not much you can do you
could try to stretch it but that then
that distorts the the map yeah so that
that that one is a little difficult to
see on the phone and so I had to balance
see the the size of the bubbles there
are as large as they can be without
touching each other the this the the
Sunset Park and the water park
these ones are almost touching each
other and then the numbers that is
largest they can be without coming out
of the of the bubbles and the labels are
the same size as the numbers and also
they can they couldn't be much larger
otherwise they would be overlapping each
other so what's a lot of trial and error
and looking at the devices where people
could be watching could be looking at
these the laptops are very easy but
phones are very difficult so you have to
try to make it as large as you can so
it's easier to see on the phone and try
to make it taller rather than wider all
right any any more questions
yeah oh yeah it's the map the the baka
is the map not what Levi are the bar
charts the that map so for the map I
tried several things like I tried Google
Maps but then they did you have to have
these API and then I'll sink examples of
people online where that created
something and when you go to the website
it said not available anymore so I
didn't want that to happen and I
couldn't I couldn't quite do this on on
Google Maps so that one was soon
eliminated the one I used just before
this was volume it's another library
right we can do do maps and that worked
well the issue was saving the mark I
created as an image like as a PNG or SVG
that that I'm doing here I couldn't
quite make it work so I couldn't write
make the nice save it to a nice format I
had to save it as an HTML file the
democra created on volume and then I was
manually taking screenshots of the of
the HTML file so I'll open the HTML take
a screenshot and then crop it so it was
not as easy as as we'd walk in ended up
being so that's why I'm using bak it the
main reason is it let me do everything I
need it's always going to be there and I
can easily save what I create as a an
image a PNG image or SVG image there is
an issue that's what I'm showing here
the SVG image does not load well into
HTML pages that's why I use the PNG but
we can get there and any more questions
so so I have the issue of
so it all is open that's all right and
let's see
actually I should be looking at two ones
so I created this folder where I'm gonna
keep the despite date NYC 2019 folder
where I'm gonna try to keep these as a
static version of what I showed here
while I still keep working on the rest
sometime kind of try to come back and
try to show you an example from here so
I'd see what happens if I click here
okay that does not show as HTML so I do
have the final presentation page and I
can point people to the HTML through
through this page
but I'll just download
so does I'm gonna talk about this at the
end that I sync these there you go so
this is how you do it
this is the HTML version of one of the
notebooks and it's it's here still
there's a link for it and I can do that
because I set up github pages on my
github account and it's it's easy to set
up you can just follow the instructions
from github
and when you set up when you set it up
you get like your home page github dot
IO and then for every project you create
you get a page create a limit or as long
as you allow that in the repository so
you'll see can here that is this is my
name my github dot IO account slash the
name of the project oh you cannot see
that sliced / missiles so this is a good
way to point people to the HTML version
so this is the github that IO kind of
like a your own guitar page and then for
each project you just need to write
slash name of the project and then you
can write the path to the HTML version
of your notebook and and you'll and
you'll be able to see the HTML version
notebook pages yeah yeah
yeah this one works for me we're using
the github pages yeah
what do you certain the repository for
it to know that it should redirect to
that repository so slash measles yeah
you just allow github pages to build a
page for that repository and that's it
so the is that we see when we go to your
name io / missus and it can be the
readme but I change it to be an index I
want to answer to have a difference with
me because the readme has all the
instructions for you guys and I want
this I want this page to be kind of the
project landing page for anyone who is
interesting learning about it and not
particularly interested in the code so
in the repository hi
I have the readme which has all the
instructions for this tutorial a
tutorial in the requirements the package
requirements and I have the index and
the index is is the landing page for the
project with with a nice text in the
next nice images here yeah the rendering
here is not as nice and we're actually
built to the page but that's why yes yes
if you know when you create if you
create just to read me MD without the
index MD will show you the the readme MD
so if you want to overwrite the readme
MD you can just create index MD and that
that will be the one displayed yeah any
any more questions at this moment
all right so I would like to show you a
similar example but with a few additions
in this case horizontal bar chart and is
there's an additional element of
displaying the percentage of the cases
so again let's let's play I already gave
the answer let's play the spot the
difference so what in this case we are
we are showing the number of missile
cases by by age group and on the left
hand side you have what you'd get as a
default bar chart on on on matplotlib
and on the right hand side it's kind of
my improved version of it can you guys
tell me what differences do you spot
here yeah so it's a horizontal bar chart
this I love a vertical bar chart do ya
do why do you think I used horizontal
instead of vertical yeah and and and the
labels are kind of long so when the
labels are small like the demands were
in the sir like if the labels are small
like like like the months it's easy to
do on the vertical bar chart but when
the labels are long like these ones it's
better to the horizontal bar chart yeah
yeah yeah that's a good point too
any other differences so it's horizontal
instead of vertical I think someone
mentioned the percentages so here these
four categories make make it add up to
the total that's why I'm doing the
giving the percentage so in addition of
showing the number of cases the
percentage is useful to highlight the
group that's that's more affected and by
how much difference so you can see that
the the group that had more cases were
the kids between one and four year olds
was 277 cases but it's helpful to see
it's four that 47%
sorry 43% of all the cases here they are
kind of similar but still it's useful
it's particularly useful say when you go
to the number of missile cases by the
vaccination status of the people got the
measles and it's quite impressive that
most of the people like 73% were
unvaccinated which is kind of expected
people don't get we're not vaccinated
the ones that will get more more of the
disease but okay so coming back we have
the horizontal bar chart we have the
percentages and again we have all the
other differences that we already
spotted on on the other on the first
case of the vertical bar chart so I'm
just gonna again run this close that
start kernel to make sure okay so this
is gonna be so even though I did
different notebooks there was there's a
lot of a lot of notes and cold shared
it's it's very similar so I'm going to
show you just blow the libraries again
it's gonna be we're gonna be using
matplotlib we read the data the same way
we read we're at the data before just
now it's the the number of cases by the
age group again we extract that context
information about the start months in
the end months using the same code the
total number of cases again using the
same code we struck the data to plot
which in this case is the categories of
the age groups and the number of cases
for each age group and as before we
create like the default matplotlib bar
chart and now we're gonna do gonna save
that so we have to show we have a well
we have to rope to show in the
presentation and then you already
mention all these these these changes
that I did and the code is very similar
the the difference is use bar H instead
of just bar so
oh yes yeah that's a good point
I'm gonna do it without this without the
invert y-axis so the default who was was
this one and I found it easier to read
from top to bottom as like starting from
the younger age to the older age did I
think it'll still be valid maybe just my
personal preference but I do find it
easier to read from top to bottom
and and to have that age progression
from top to bottom that's why I inverted
the axis yeah that that that's a good
that's a good chain well spotted that
that difference it was not the case in
the other one okay so now we invert the
axis and that's how you get the inverted
order and the what's new here is the dis
creation of the percentages which is
done with the following code here okay
so it's kind of this the same codes as
we are used used before to just add the
number of cases as labels but now in
addition to to just the number of cases
we are also doing adding this string
which gonna show us the percentages and
we are running running the percentages
to the nearest integer so that if just
if you don't do the rounding you'll have
decimal cases and then it becomes
cluttered in the graph so you always
want to provide a useful information but
hide unnecessary details like the
decimal points that would clutter the
graph so that's why we are doing the
rounding there and and this is the exact
code that is providing the percentage
information which is the only thing that
changed from from the previous one they
did the addition okay
yep yep yes
the the get weed gets the the the size
of the part chart and and that's just to
provide the where the position where to
display the text so an to to I want to
display the text immediately after the
bar chart and actually I'm giving it an
extra five of spacing to note so that
the labels are not right on top so if I
don't go I don't give him the five
they're gonna be right on top and it's
kind of can be a little cluttered so
that's why I'm giving a likes to yeah
that's a way for you to get the weed
directly from the graph yeah yeah
I'm trying to figure out to get width is
giving you that length of the bar and
then you're adding a string to it again
oh yeah
so the the get wid will give me the
number which is the number of cases one
or two right that that's the do because
it's a result of bar chart it is to wit
in it it's more easy to think it's the
length of the bar chart on the
horizontal axis but it's to it because
the horizontal so the weeds can gonna
give you the 100 into the 277 and so on
okay and then I used that also to
calculate the ratio of that weight
compared with total number of cases and
I'm going to apply 100 to get the
percentage yeah so I transform so the
get weight gives you a number and I
transform it to a string yeah because I
mean I could use it from I could do it
from the data yes but this is why I will
this way I guarantee that I'm doing it
in the right order
I flipped the axis and so on so then you
have to you have to be if you're gonna
do it from the diet you have to account
for all the changes you did you me mail
you'd have to flip the order of the data
as well so this way you actually they're
accessing the the the pot as it is at
the moment you are not concerned about
what we read it to the pot already
all right
okay any more questions here yeah yeah
well that's actually interesting
question and so the main reason why
people got the well the trigger was
someone went some from us went into a
country someone and vaccinated went to a
country where there was measles and they
got measles there and they came back
with measles and they spread it through
a community where there were low
vaccination rates so the main reason why
people got measles is they were not
vaccinated okay
that said measles happened in the
particular community
well most cases were in a particular
community it was not just that community
if you read the newspaper articles about
it they this specifically named what
community that is and but so I had that
question yesterday for the New York
Times presenter when you talked about
ethics I talked to them and my my my I
don't have the right answer so my point
is I will not name the community we in
any of my materials because the data is
not available so even though a
journalist can go and ask the New York
City Health Department or ask doctors
what's going on and they may tell him or
we finding more cases in this community
and there is no data that I know
separating the the cases by communities
or traits of communities also because I
think that's not allowed
you there there you shouldn't be
collecting some information about about
some what people privacy issues and I
try they're not allowed or if it's
collected because it's useful it's not
it's not automate to be public so I
don't know I'm not I am NOT expert on
here on this and because I don't have
the right answer I chose not to mention
the specific community it happened
because the main point is not that
community or another because in other
places of the country it also happens
and they toured there were different
communities
can happen in all kinds of different
communities so the main point is people
were not vaccinated and that's what I'm
trying to make a cross that's the point
I'm trying to make here but yeah if you
read the newspaper articles journalists
do mention what what what was the main
community affected here in New York but
there's no data for that that I know of
I think that's because it it's not
allowed to collect that data or made it
but make it public so as a data
scientist that's actually you should be
aware of the ethical issues if the data
does not exist it's probably a good hint
that you shouldn't be showing it to you
in your visuals because for example I
could the same way I tell you I write
here some lines with providing
additional information I could write
most of the cases were in this community
but should you be doing that I don't
have the right answer and I think at the
moment is I shouldn't be doing that
because one is not the most relevant
information and may distract people from
what's important which is people where
that at the measles who just did the
missiles the main reason was they did
were not vaccinated so and that should
be the focus and measles happen in many
different places in US and many
different communities and the common
factor is that the people who did not
were not vaccinated were the ones who
were more at risk of getting the disease
and who won that the disease all right
yeah
question
- yeah so these were like journalists
include like journals from important
journals like the New York Times they
would mention and this is a particular
religious community and you'd mention it
and so journalists are know much better
no more ethics than I do or the data
scientists - and they they are very
strict on their ethics so if they do it
is because they they they see there that
it's ethical for them to do there's
benefit on doing it so it does provide
information to the wider community and
it may it certainly helped the actually
it certainly helped in writing the the
New York City Health Department knowing
what was the particular communities that
were more affected and actually they
focus their efforts on increasing
vaccinations on those communities so
that's that's helpful information but
here what I'm doing is I'm creating data
visualizations of it and the question is
should I be putting that information in
the visualization I don't know the right
answer and I tried I prefer to be
defensive and because I don't know it I
I don't I don't do it and I think that
the main reason was people are not
vaccinated and but if you read the news
articles they will mention
if someone to them prospective on what
would be conscious vaccination yeah yeah
so this is kind of descriptive
statistics describing the problem with
doing nice easy-to-understand
visualizations and putting the focus on
the main factor which is people not
being vaccinated which is the common
factor across all communities all right
any more questions
so we have half an hour okay so let's
get back to the main notebook so I
showed you that one the the horizontal
bar chart and now the next one is also a
result a bar chart the code is exactly
the same let's just highlight the
insight which is the main point of this
descriptive analysis is that the bar
chart clearly shows that most of the
people who who got the disease who got
measles were unvaccinated right 73
percent of the cases were on people that
were not vaccinated and there were a few
cases in like 7 percent in people that
had the one dose only and even fewer
cases on those that had the two doses of
the vaccine and there were several
several cases that people didn't know
that their status actually those those
people didn't know their physician
status were adults
normally the the kids nowadays will get
the vaccine or know if they got it or
not
but oh there are people that deluxe in
and and got killed and got the measles
so set seven seven percent of the cases
here in New York were on people that had
the windows-only and five percent were
on people that had the two doses yeah
as I said in the introduction the the
vaccine is not perfect but it is very
effective where so here the windows as
93% effectiveness and to does is 97%
effectiveness and so actually it also
depending on your age you may have
gotten the vaccine when there was only
one dose or may have gotten vaccine
where there were two doses and maybe you
got updated then you went to get the
second dose or he didn't so there are
all those different factors so the when
the vaccine was first introduction was
introduced in 63 1963 was just one dose
in 1989 they start introducing the
second dose recommending the two doses
so you can you can see how people from
before 1989 may have gotten all into one
dose and not get updated actually from
I'm from Port so I got the vaccines
there and I think I got ended up getting
three doses I got the first recommended
one dose and then I got the the after
that I got the recommended two doses
yeah I'm not I'm not expert on that but
I I actually I was curious about it and
I went to read my vaccination records
and from what I could read from the
nurse writing it seems like I got the
the first one dose and then when the the
new recommendation came I got the the
new two doses the first in the second
yeah so it may have happened to people
like things like that they get they
either get the new recommended doses or
not so yeah there's probably depends on
what people have got in the past and
what they updated or not okay
yeah that's a good point so that's why
so you could you could say well if the
if the two doses are 97% effective then
this should only be 3% but that's not
the case because the context is flipped
here right this is from those who got
the vaccine how many had one dose or two
doses what you are asking is from the
population how do we have information of
how many people got the vaccine the one
dose or the two doses so we can do that
calculation I didn't look for that data
I imagine it is available or it should
be probably on the CDC the Center for
Disease Control's
website but yeah that that would be the
right way of approach approaching that
question nevertheless this data itself
shows that most of the cases were on on
unvaccinated people and I I'm I didn't
look at the data but generally speaking
the vaccination rates are still high in
the u.s. even though there are spots
where it's not as high as they should be
to provide herd immunity given that they
are assumedly high know much larger than
the 50 percent then this data itself
shows that you know there's there's few
and pure and vaccinated people and here
there there most of the cases so it does
give to give you an indication that to
answer that question without the whole
data all right so yeah that that's kind
of the main point of this is one of the
main points of the descriptive analysis
most of the cases were the large
majority kids weren't vaccinated people
the previous point was
many of the cases were in children
actually again most of the cases were in
children because they they are the ones
more at risk because they can only take
the vaccines at the certain stages in in
in their in their at certain stages of
their age and the other point is the the
outbreak peaked in April it's just so
happen in April the New York City Health
Department took stronger actions and
after that it went down so it's a good
indication that the actions they took
helps curb the outbreak even though it's
not cause causes you cannot imply
causation here but it's a good
indication okay so now the final one so
I'm going to skip this one because it's
it's the code is the same as that one
before yes yeah so that is available and
I didn't I didn't use that but that
would be kind of a second round of of
plots that I can create or or anyone can
create so they have this table they tell
you that those so did the older the
older ones and most of them didn't know
if they were vaccinated or not yeah and
so and you'll see the the kids will
we'll have the kids add vaccinations and
I can hear the the older kids like the
teenagers sorry my mistake let me
correct that so the kids were not
vaccinated as well and so the only a few
of them at some vaccinations right and
so
across the young ages you can see that
most most of the cases did not have the
vaccine and then the older ages most of
the cases people just didn't know if
they had vaccine or not because they're
old and they didn't know it so we don't
know if they add vaccine or not yeah so
there's there's still benefit on on
trying to make a plot of these these
matrix like that I use just I I made the
purple just with the totals to highlight
the points of th groups and the
vaccination status but answer detailed
questions like that you can you one
could create a matrix pot of this data
to highlight that the answers to those
questions all right
so now the the map I'm gonna jump to the
code okay so we're going we the main
library here is Boca and as I said I try
different things end up using Boca
because it let me do what I wanted to do
and it let me save my final result as an
image format PNG and SVG so let me just
restart the kernel to make sure we are
good here so we are importing the
libraries I have a note here about some
dependencies to use the export
functionality in Boca
but I already included those
dependencies in the readme file if you
if you follow those instructions you
should have that already if not this is
the instructions you should follow to
install those dependencies so the data
again was the CSV file where I collected
the data but in addition to that I just
need the coordinates data the latitude
and longitude of each neighborhood so
you can place them in in them in the in
the New York City Map and again was just
a few neighborhoods I just I just
searched the delighted to in longitude
and collected the auto in the CSV file
so everything is being imported here
from CSV files and then that means I'd
found the files and importing them
correctly so the measles data just
having a quick look at the measles data
you'll see it's a you have the
neighborhood and
number of cases I provided here the the
date information in the in the column
header of the number of cases to keep
the context information so we always
know when these data was collected so we
have the the neighborhood names you'll
notice that some neighborhoods in some
some entries in this table are to have
two neighborhoods like this Brighton
Beach and Coney Island that's because
that's how the New York City Health
Department reported the data so I just
kept it exactly how they add it and for
the longitude and latitude because there
are different neighborhoods I just took
the average for for the neighborhoods so
it was a simple way of representing them
in the map okay so in the coordinates
data you have the neighborhood and again
you also have the cases like Brighton
Beach sloshed Coney Island and they have
glided to the longitudes and these
numbers are the averages of these
numbers for each of them Brighton Beach
and Coney Island okay as before we we
want to keep information about the start
months and end months to provide context
in our visualization so because I used
this long name here to keep the date
information it's not convenient to refer
to this column by this long name when
you are doing the coding so I'm going to
rename the columns to some more simple
names to neighborhood in cases simply
and you can see that now I couldn't even
look at all the head so you have now the
column names are neighborhood in cases
so it's easier to refer to the cases :
again we struck the totals and we
confirm that the totals add up 649 and
at least one at this point it's it's so
I have two separate data frames at this
point the number of cases by
neighborhoods and the longitude and
latitude information for its
neighborhood so here I'm merging them in
a single data frame so that it's easier
when I'm creating the visualization so
I'm using the merge functionality from
pandas merging these two data frames and
now my data frame as the neighborhood
the number of cases to latitude and
longitude for that neighborhood so
walkie uses does not use latitude and
longitude at lease
I couldn't use it it chooses marketer
marketer coordinates and I found these
an initial function that did that
conversion so this is a reference I
think was this function or something
like something similar to this function
and then I modified it to make it more
modular for for what I needed so but
this this code is inspired by by it by
this post here on Stack Exchange and
basically giving a longitude and
latitude it gives you back the
corresponding x and y marketer
coordinates which is what you need to do
the plotting with walking okay so just
to find those functions and for example
new york city's latitude and longitude
you can input that into the marketer X Y
function and it gives you the market X Y
coordinates so because we need that
marketer coordinates
we're gonna introduce that to our data
frame so given the longitude we can
apply the marketer X function to create
marketer x coordinates for for all the
neighborhoods and the matter why it's
done by applying them the marketer Y
function which needs both latitude and
longitude okay so our data frame now is
the neighborhood the case is latitude
longitude and marketer x and y
coordinates and now that we have all the
data we need we can create the map and I
have several functions here to help
creating the map so as you've seen
before the map as these circles these
bubbles and I'm n will define the size
of the circles as I said before to
optimize the space okay let's run the
codes there we go
so these the result and
as I mentioned before I optimize the
size of the circles so that they
represent different sizes for different
numbers of cases but also so that there
are as large as possible without
overlapping each other and that meant
that I actually I defined the the sizes
manual it's not like a function like
it's not a linear increase because if it
were these 473 is much bigger than all
the others just be a big blob over New
York City or even like trying to do a
square root or logarithm that I didn't
find any functional expression that
would provide a nice representation so I
actually had to do it manually and so
the sizes of the bubbles are defined
here so if the number of cases is
smaller than 10 the radius of the
bubbles going to be 25 if if if its
larger than 10 but smaller than 100 it's
going to be 35 and if it's larger than
100 and smaller than 200 it's going to
be 45 else is going to be 55 which is
the only one case Williamsburg with most
of the cases so that was a good balance
to for to provide good information in
the in the LaMotte so here it's why with
the finding a new column in the data
frame that is going to have the radius
information by applying that that that
function to the number of cases now the
the label X this function this function
here the label x offset defines where
the numbers will be positioned and and
again I had to do manual adjustments to
try to make the numbers as right in the
center okay so there was quite a lot of
manual adjustments to try to make the
map and visualization as clean as
possible so here I'm applying the
function to the number of to the number
of cases columns to create the offset
for all the neighborhoods now now here
this was where the was even more manual
so if if you try to display the light
there there's a way to
also create an automatic offset for the
labels so for the numbers relatively you
have to put them in the center you can
kind of define a few a few numbers and
it goes there you fought for but the
numbers are kind of being almost old all
the same for the same cases you could
define an automatic offset for the
levels like always put it on the right
but if I did that this guy will be on
the right and then this guy will be on
the right and it'll be like they'll be
overlapping each other so what I did
actually I did individual offsets for
each neighborhood and that's this long
manual coding here yeah so for each
neighborhood I am setting there so I'm
setting the neighborhood level x offset
and Y offset so these these numbers were
set by hand so that the labels
themselves are placed in the right place
and they don't overlap each other and
they don't overlap the other bubbles so
that was some manual work so this cartel
positron retina it is the background map
I thought I used that because as you can
see it's a very neutral background it
provides the if you look at it if people
are relatively familiar with the New
York City map they will identify this
New York City map there's New York there
so the background is I pick this
background because it's neutral and then
you can highlight the the means of state
itself and okay well
okay so at this point you have all the
data you need just start by providing
the backgrounds you create yeah so here
it sets the the size of the map great
the initial create the figure to provide
the the size of the map so here I'm just
providing the title and here is that are
those additional notes about the number
of cases about the end of the outbreak
and about the sources and here I'm just
positioning those notes in the right
places like some go above some go below
okay
again I removed the axes this provides
this source provides information about
the source of the mapping which is this
Open Street Map and cartodb
I also provided a note because when you
print it as a PNG that that informations
disappears from the map okay and yeah so
here is how you create the the bubbles
the circles when still you have the data
ready
and here's how we add the number of
cases and here is how we add the
neighborhood levels so first I did all
the manual work of defining where things
are going to be and then once you have
that you just just use the codes to to
place - to show it in the map and yes so
this map can this could be a dynamic map
interactive map where you can zoom in
and out and move it around I chose to
make it static so because I want people
to focus on on the neighborhoods where
the cases actually happened if I if I
let the user change the map by zooming
in or zooming out or panning left and
right you may just go out of you and
then none does not come back so in this
case is an example of a static image the
static map is better than the dynamic
map okay and yeah that's so so I'm
saving them up as SVG and PNG as I said
the only issue I've at the moment with
Bach is that I cannot easily so the SVG
version or on an HTML page when I try to
do that the the background tiles of the
city map are not showing so that's
something I'm still working on so that's
why I'm using also the PNG version and
yeah as you support that so that was the
bulky part and as I said I present all
of these in a dedicated web page which
uses github pages with the defaults I
don't do anything fancy I know we'd get
up wedges you can use Jacqueline and so
on or who go to make it look more nice
and create your own your own styling but
I just use the plain style so it's just
white and I I provide like textual
information as the one that I've been
telling you so far and I define the
images with sizes that will show on all
the screens like on the laptop and on
the phones so these are all the images
that I've showed you and like I said the
map is a little more challenging because
it's kind of a dream is that it's more
wide so I stab believe you
can still read it on your phone maybe a
little a little more challenging than
than the other ones yes so and those are
that's the final product of all of these
it's the the way you present to the
general public in this case I use a
github page because it it's very easy
it's very fast to load yeah do you have
any questions so let me just go back to
the beginning again acknowledges to the
organization everyone involved are
organizing this conference and thank you
for selecting to do this presentation
and again New York City Health
Department for providing the great data
yeah open for more questions thank you
yes so since you left to raise their
hand first
actively track things like the
neighborhood where you had to hard-code
all those things
what kind of approach would you take if
you wanted to
yeah oh and update so yes I yeah so hmm
i I did that I was doing this while the
outbreak was going on and basically when
the New York City Health Department up
take the data about once a week and when
they did that I would update my data and
just run the same code and there and get
the new the new map yeah so uh-oh the
neighborhood's done yes so at some point
the the the neighborhood's kind of
stabilized there were always the same
ones so if they added a new one
I'll def to add a new entry on my CSV
file of the neighborhood and latitude
and longitude for it yeah I would have
to add the neighborhood's as they added
them as well yeah at some point they did
remove some of them so I have more
neighborhoods in my data than there is
in the in the missile site at the moment
because when it was going on the data
was very preliminary so they would do a
tribute some cases to some neighborhoods
and then the next update they would
actually correct to the correct
neighborhood so yeah when it was going
on I had I can quickly show you like
some some of that data did that data is
not inside these dedicated folder for
the conference so everything I showed is
in this dedicated folder but here in the
project there is so for example this is
the cages by age and you see the
different versions oh let me so the
first version was from always it's all
from September 1st when it started - May
20 and then there was an update on May
24th and so that's also why I have the
first columns being the start date and
end date that was the way up for me for
capturing the different versions as they
were updating it and so I have I have
this for all all the data we did the
different parts versions for for this
talk I provided on the final version
because it's clean and it's less
confusing
yeah and some of them had to be Excel
files like the neighborhood's solid EV
each one sheet for each data update and
then when I was loading the data out the
sheet at the date of the update and out
picked the sheet with with the latest
date yeah any questions yeah so I don't
remember talking my head I can I can
talk with you after to try to give you a
reference but github has an easy an easy
reference guide for out to do it and
basically the way I did it first
I created this github dot il it's kind
of your presentation page for github and
after you do that then when sorry then
when you after you do this one then when
you do a new project you just go to some
settings which I can show you after and
you just click a button allow github
pages here and then you just do your
github that IO slash the name of the
project and it points directly to your
readme or your index dot nd so it's it's
it's easy so when you clean now when I
create a new project I will just allow
github page here in the eleven a github
page to display the it's kind of the
landing page for the project more for
the general public like design
any more questions I'll show you the
link after
right
oh thank you for coming to this 9:00
a.m. talk